[Musique]
Madeleine blémorin Hélène buzetti Michel
soget bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir bonne
année bonne année
les images viennent d'arriver on voit
monsieur Trudeau qui s'installe à Manuel
Lopez au bras d'eau le président du
Mexique et Monsieur Biden bien sûr qui
vont se rencontrer à des bilatérales
aujourd'hui donc deux bilatérales et
demain ça sera le sommet des trois
madeleines est-ce que c'est important
comme sommet qu'est-ce qu'on surveille
évidemment que c'est important pour le
Canada c'est important pour l'économie
canadienne c'est important aussi d'un
point de vue d'immigration on parlant
d'économie la ministre du commerce
international et sur place le Canada a
eu chaud récemment lorsque les
États-Unis proposaient d'accorder un
crédit d'impôts pour les véhicules
électriques construits aux États-Unis le
Canada a eu peur de perdre toute son
industrie de véhicule électrique de
l'avenir avec un crédit d'IMP avec
lequel le Canada aurait pas pu
compétitionner ça c'est réglé donc il y
a moins de tension côté économique mais
il y a quand même des enjeux notamment
avec le la loi qui a été adoptée aux
États-Unis
pour réduire l'inflation qui injecte
massivement de l'argent dans l'économie
américaine pour développer toute
l'industrie verte le Canada se retrouve
face à ça en se disant est-ce qu'on est
capable de concurrencer face à de
pareils investissements donc le Canada
doit non seulement agir d'un point de
vue national mais essayez de s'arranger
pour que les investissements américains
profitent aussi au Canada d'une part on
pourra parler d'immigration
et Michel l'immigration malgré tout
reste un peu l'éléphant comme j'ai
plutôt dans la pièce là on a vu monsieur
Biden aller à la frontière des
États-Unis du Mexique
oui absolument et en fait le Canada lui
sa préoccupation principale c'est
évidemment avec sa frontière la question
de l'entente sur les tiers-paysures que
qu'il tente désespérément de renégocier
avec les États-Unis ça fait quand même
pas mal de temps qu'on nous dit que
c'est en processus de renégociation mais
on envoie toujours pas de déboucher et
en fait dans ces sommets là je pense que
la préoccupation du Canada est toujours
un peu la même c'est-à-dire que sur la
question migratoire en particulier les
enjeux du Nord ne font pas le poids par
rapport aux enjeux à la frontière sud
des États-Unis celle avec le Mexique et
donc le Canada toujours peur d'être un
peu
amalgamé dans un débat nord-américain
alors qu'il préférait qu'on ait des
déductions beaucoup plus bilatérales
pour maintenir son son lien privilégié
avec les États-Unis parce que sur la
question migratoire les États-Unis
s'inquiètent pas mal plus de ce qui se
passe en couple en haut bien sûr lors de
la BIL Général Trudeau Biden Michel C
peut-être ça sera les derniers la
dernière poignée de main pour le chemin
Roxane pour l'entendre
mais c'est quand même remarquable vois
ça se met où les bilatérales sont plus
importantes pour le Canada que le sommet
lui-même c'est plus important d'avoir du
temps que le président des États-Unis
pour essayer de régler un certain nombre
de problèmes Madeleine les a nommés que
de d'en parler à trois
évidemment le sommet des fruits amigoses
reste et donc il est il est important
comme rendez-vous mais c'est pas ce qui
va décider à la table des trois c'est ce
qui va se décider en bilatérale qui est
important puis un bilatéral
Hélène me disait écoutez monsieur Bidel
est dans des problèmes énormes
politiques aux États-Unis à cause de la
frontière sud on l'accuse même dans son
parti de dire que vous faites absolument
rien trouvé
c'est pas c'est pas le chemin des femmes
qui va vraiment intéresser le président
des États-Unis cette semaine et quand on
parle de cette entente là si un début de
négociation qui fait ou même si les
négociations sont avancées va-t-il
falloir après ratifier cette entente là
et dans le contexte actuel avec le
nouveau Congrès à majorité républicaine
ça vient compliquer encore les choses on
a vu que Kevin mccartier pour devenir
président de la Chambre a dû faire des
compromis à parler par exemple d'un
retour d'un projet de mur avec le
Mexique on est loin d'une renégociation
sur une entente sur les tiers pays sûr
qui est un problème minuscule par
rapport à la frontière sud donc ça
devient un petit peu je trouve difficile
d'envisager à court terme que cette
question-là soit réglée il regarde
monsieur todo en disant vous me parlez
vraiment de 30 000 personnes en haut et
vous pensez que c'est un problème j'en
ai 300 000 en bas qui rentrent très bien
bon je suis content de parler de ça les
F-35 parce que il y a eu comme ça des
histoires politiques il y a des livres
qui ont d'ailleurs été écrit là-dessus
les hélicoptères monsieur Trudeau
monsieur chrétien veut dire j'achète
très peu ce que monsieur mallonnais
avait commandé ce Trudeau arrive dis-moi
j'achète pas les avions que monsieur
Harper a commandé et voici qu'on va
mettre Hélène 19 milliards dans les
mêmes avions qu'un peu avaient
finalement commandé il y a 13 ans oui on
a vraiment l'impression d'un retour à la
case départ 13 ans plus tard le quoique
on l'avait annoncé l'année passée là
c'est 88 donc c'est 12 ans plus tard
mais pour être honnête faut quand même
remarquer il faut quand même faire
souligner que l'avion F35 a quand même
changé depuis la première annonce de
2010 quand Peter Maki est le ministre à
l'époque avait fait venir à Ottawa ou
une réplique le miniature de cette de
cet avion puis il y avait pouce en l'air
annoncé que voilà c'était fait on
passait commande de 65 appareils à
l'époque on parlait vraiment d'un
appareil très de l'ordre du prototype il
y avait quelque chose encore un peu
théorique dans ce projet qui qui était
en voie de construction 12 ans plus tard
l'appareil est beaucoup plus achevé bien
sûr qu'il y a encore des pépins on
constate mais on ne parle plus vraiment
de la même chose il faut aussi se
rappeler que en 2010 oui les
conservateurs avaient dit on passe
commande mais en 2012 eux-mêmes avaient
reconnu qui avait des problèmes
justement parce que c'était un appareil
très préliminaire et peu achevé et ils
avaient décidé de repartir le processus
ils avaient dit qu'il pouvait encore
acheter des F35 mais il ne s'y était pas
engagé alors il y a quand même un peu un
flottement donc quand monsieur Trudeau a
dit en 2015 non non je les achèterai pas
c'est pas comme s'il mettait fin ou
qu'ils rompait une entente prise par les
conservateurs mais néanmoins c'est sûr
qu'on a l'impression de tourner un petit
peu en rond au cours des 12 dernières
années pourquoi Michel C on achète des
avions comme cela au Canada
d'abord parce qu'on est membre de l'OTAN
parce qu'on la défense du Canada doit
être assurée et dans des temps troublés
au plan international avec ce qui se
passe en Russie on a une frontière avec
la Russie on a tendance à l'oublier
voilà une alors c'est des avions qui
vont patrouiller là mais pour revenir à
ce qu'elle a disait il y a toujours un
problème de pollyphes quand on achète
des projets des projets comme ceux-là le
problème c'est que si on rentre très tôt
dans le processus on va participer à la
recherche et au développement il y a des
industries canadiennes qui vont en
profiter ils sont rentables on a un
appareil achevé mais la recherche est le
développement est pas mal faite alors
c'est toujours ça que les gouvernements
essaient de de négocier même pour les 18
qu'on a actuellement
des années 80 ça c'est négocier mais
c'était ça la question on disait hey il
faut des retombées dans la recherche au
Canada et si on achète l'autre l'autre
marque ou si on achète des avions
français on n'aura pas
là c'est le temps que fait qu'on a
beaucoup moins de ces retombées là ça
c'était un peu dommage d'un autre côté
on achète un avion ne serait-ce que qui
vont être adapté à notre climat ce qui
est pas un détail et pour un peu moins
cher aussi Madeleine est-ce que le
terrain politique est
solide pour Monsieur Trudeau là-dessus
bon bah les conservateurs on le disait
voulait vous l'avions de gens là donc ne
peuvent pas dire on n'en veut plus
maintenant non mais pourraient
facilement critiquer juste un Trudeau
d'avoir pris finalement beaucoup trop de
temps pour l'annoncer d'avoir d'être
retourné comme le disait Hélène à la
case départ ils auraient beau jeu de le
dire notez Patrice concierge pas au
Parlement du Canada en ce moment la
reprise des travaux c'est fin janvier
notez qu'on est à la veille du sommet
des trois amigos donc c'est peut-être un
très très bon moment pour le
gouvernement canadien de faire cette
annonce là on en parle pendant une
journée on redit encore une fois que
Justin Trudeau auront pu sa promesse
qu'il avait dit qu'il n'achèterait pas
les F-35 pour finalement changer d'idées
donc on parle mais il va pouvoir
présenter cette nouvelle là dans un
contexte nord-américain de protection du
continent de modernisation de du
nord-ade c'est beaucoup plus facile à
faire aux côtés de Joe Biden que
lorsqu'on est présent en Chambre des
communes devant les confitures qui
peuvent dire au gouvernement que
finalement l'achat est beaucoup plus
cher que prévu par leur faute parce
qu'ils ont entendu échangé d'idées et
comme vous dites pour les Américains
pour Washington c'est une annonce qui
est qui va être normal que on va dire
tant mieux ces avions là se parlent
Patrick c'est intéressant parce qu'ils
ont le même système de communication si
les États-Unis ont le F35 si des alliés
qui patrouillent aussi dans le Nord
canadien on le F35 c'est plus facile
d'avoir des opérations communes et ça
les militaires vont vous le dire c'est
pour ça entre autres que aussi vous
laissez avions là c'est janvier toujours
dans ces affaires
mais ça met aussi en lumière tout tout
le défi toujours dans les plus gros
problèmes les gros programmes
d'acquisition militaire l'enjeu de appel
d'offres pas appel d'offres une des
raisons pour laquelle le gouvernement a
voulu reprendre tout le processus c'est
qu'il voulait un appel d'offres en bonne
et due forme le concept étant qu'un
appel d'offres nous permet d'obtenir le
meilleur prix sauf que dans le milieu
militaire le milieu de la défense on
rétorque par contre que souvent les
appels d'offres prolonge beaucoup les
processus d'acquisition et ça aussi ça
en train des coûts dans le cas qui nous
occupe il a fallu acquérir d'autres F-18
des vieux F18 de l'Australie je pense
compléter notre flotte qui commençait à
être vieillissante et ça aussi ce sont
des coûts pas des coûts d'acquisition
mais qui qui gonflent la facture totale
et donc il y a de plus en plus de gens
qui remettent en question la philosophie
de l'appel d'offres à tout prix
et d'ailleurs dans ce domaine là et dans
d'autres domaines aussi on le vit dans
d'autres exemples c'est et d'autant que
les militaires peuvent mettre 4 5 6 22
exigences sur le tel panneau de bord de
sorte que appelle doivent c'est pas
simple non plus un mot à Michel C on n'a
pas pu s'empêcher hier qu'on a vu ces
images du Brésil de faire des liens avec
le 6 janvier
2021 à Washington
des partisans qui refusent le verdict
électoral et non pas encouragé mais en
fait pas décourager par bolsonaro dans
ce dans ce cas là
qui est troublant dans Ça c'est que là
on voit l'exemple américain qui s'étend
à d'autres pays et
des définitions même de la démocratie
que le perdant accepte les résultats de
l'élection si on commence à dire à
chaque fois que que
il y a eu de la fraude et de la fraude
majeure puis pas prouver plus au bureau
au Brésil qu'aux États-Unis
on va voir le problème avec la
démocratie elle-même je sais que
certains de ces dirigeants l'homme se
trompe pas des grandes démocrates mais à
un moment donné il va falloir
s'interroger sur comment
quel effet ça peut avoir sur le système
démocratique lui-même c'est pas un bon
effet et c'est aller loin elle est loin
il y a beaucoup de monde
oui absolument mais je veux rebondir sur
ce que Michel dit sur cette importance
de jouer le jeu démocratique et je ferai
un lien avec le Canada vous savez
pendant les vacances l'ancien chef
conservateur est Renaud tout le fait une
sortie que quand même
fatigué quand il le dit il a appelé pour
plus de similité dans le discours public
il le dit moi j'aimerais que les les
fameux drapeau le F Trudeau qui qui se
sont propagés beaucoup notamment avec le
convoi des camionnettes que ces drapeaux
là disparaissent évidemment ça ça peut
être un peu froissé dans les dans les
rangs conservateurs parce qu'on peut
imaginer que ce sont surtout des
partisans conservateurs qui disent à
Monsieur Trudeau d'aller se faire voir
mais ce que Monsieur auto disait c'est
que c'est pas bon de manière générale
dans le discours politique d'avoir ce
genre de ton acrimonieux et je
remarquerai que son successeur le chef
actuel pierre pollièvre
reconnu du boulet des lèvres que c'est
vrai que c'était pas bien il y a dit il
faut quand même entendre cette colère
pourquoi elle existe donc il y a un
petit un petit malaise dans les grands
conservateurs on voit pas tous les
choses la même façon
oui colère mais attention de pas tirer
toujours sur les institutions
démocratiques sur les leaders en disant
que c'est des bandits mais justement
parce que ça nous donne finalement une
menace voilée sur la solidité de nos
institutions démocratiques il y a eu
débordements aux États-Unis il y a eu
débordements au Brésil avec pas des
conséquences si grave pour le moment
mais toujours avec cette peur qui
pourrait y avoir des débordements encore
une fois donc qu'est-ce qui pourrait se
passer au Canada par exemple la
prochaine fois il y a eu de la gravelle
qui a été jetée contre Justin Trudeau il
y a eu ce qu'on voit là mais c'est comme
si on a l'impression que dans les
extrêmes on va un peu trop loin
Madeleine Hélène Michel C merci beaucoup
à très bientôt au revoir bonne soirée au
revoir au revoir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI